[Applaudissements]
la photocopieuse mon chéri ya de la
photo il a fait son défilé tout bien je
change agression directe jody qu'il ya
dans un concert où ça va mieux lui là
mais encore perdu vous laisserez une
nouvelle chance lundi dans un autre défi
est donc au micro s'il vous plaît vous
avez un pardon lundi je vous laisserai
une nouvelle chance à merci j'ai pas
peur moi y'a pas de soucis un autre
affrontement offrait un nouveau jeu tous
les deux d'accord rencontre est d'accord
ça fait plaisir mais oui mais si ce
n'est pas tricher jamais triché ah bon
j'ai appris à deux jours que le catch
c'était pas lui ça m'a pris cinq jours
trois aides pour le découvrir
voilà mais pas le replay donc la
photocopieuse toute la semaine on suit
les aventures à la rédaction de tpm paix
là où tout se prépare dans la journée et
aujourd'hui on a pris le bêtisier toutes
les scènes coupées les scènes ratées
avec bertrand avec mathieu avec tout le
monde c'est parti salut ziyi c'est mon
cher
s'attendre quand tu veux j'ai un dégât
des eaux
pourquoi megan de chez moi c'est une
tannée je ne peux rien faire
est ce que tu peux y eut donc tu es
vraiment agir est mon pote hashtag
vénéra jeta coûte pas la panacée
tagro strict elle est désolée je me
défoule
pour son anniversaire strip tease
d'erika moulet sa défense quand même
bernard maymou et oui moi la blague
quand tu m'as dit au début je dis ouais
c'était ma chute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a dû le retour de m